education is vital in preventing disease
and poverty and improving standards of
living governments typically donor
that's enough in this and they need to
be more substantial and sustained
commitment to as funding and financing
of education the reform of education
services globally this is a major global
is here and it's very important that's
how business works for government to
identify education that is going to help
to increase jobs it's not all about
education systems in schools it's also
about investment and about kind of
education that is provided and this has
to be relevant to the needs of employers
but also a needs of communities and
people increases and this challenge a
vital mouth meet the growing needs of
young people commune to the workforce we
need funding education is vital to for a
different future for a low-carbon
economy or radically different ways of
continuing and the levels of consumption
so education investment in education is
what allowed